[Música]
ah
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah
bueno
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah
ahora
[Música]
l
[Aplausos]
[Música]
a
la verdad decidió no soy una persona muy
conocida no soy una persona del
espectáculo de la farándula saben quién
soy soy solo una bailarina de marinera
y es que la marinera tiene por esencia
contar historias de amor contar
historias de amor del día a día
acontecimientos de cada uno de ustedes
de la vida real es por eso que querido
iniciar esta presentación bailando lees
y conectándome con cada uno de ustedes
para contarles uno de los episodios más
impactantes de mi vida personal en los
últimos seis años
si hablamos de marinera nos podemos
tomar todo un congreso de una semana
pero por el tiempo que me ha dado tetis
se lo agradezco es que la marinera es el
baile al amor que se me entrega esa
pasión me ha dado
ella la oportunidad de hablarles en
estos 15 minutos y por muchos personas y
niños alrededor del mundo
la esencia asimile su mano y la esencia
de la marinera el hueso chiquitito que
tú lo puedes agarrar con tus manos es un
baile que rinde tributo y homenaje al
amor al amor entre seres humanos todos
el que conoce el vestuario el que hace
las áreas de teror febre el campo la
cierra todo 33 millones de peruanos
bailamos marinera
entonces aparte que es un baile de amor
rinde también homenaje a los cuatro
elementos de la naturaleza efectivamente
porque cuando bailamos esos movimientos
de la falda el contorneo de la cadera el
movimiento ondulante del poncho asemejan
las olas del mar y el trabajo arduo de
nuestros pescadores la historia en
nuestro mar somos viento porque cada vez
que revolotea mos ese pañuelo al aire al
cielo
acariciamos los sentimientos más
hermosos que brotan cuando bailamos por
eso es que nos sentimos volar y somos
aire somos viento como fuego porque cada
metida de cara a cada acercamiento de
los cuerpos y fuego que quema es pasión
te sientes vivo y cálido
y somos tierra porque cada juego de pies
invita al pasado al presente y es el
empuje del futuro que queremos un futuro
mejor eso es la marinera
y en esos revoloteos en esas caricias al
suelo abrazamos a nuestros ancestros y
todos los misterios que están en la
tierra vibran cuando bailamos marineras
porque ustedes también bailan
[Música]
ese movimiento y bailando su pie
izquierdo y apoyo hiciste es un cruce de
bailamos marinera y en esta vida todos
bailamos diferentes ritmos diferentes
tiempos diferentes facetas pero yo les
aseguro que todos bailamos
la marinera ha hecho que yo llegué aquí
a ustedes la marinera me ha dado
demasiado y de todo así como el amor nos
hace tocar la gloria y la naturaleza con
su sabiduría tan majestuosa nos impacta
el amor y la naturaleza cuando no lo
sabemos cuidar tiene furia y esa furia
cuando arremete contra nosotros duele y
duele sobremanera hay que cuidarlos y
hay que cuidar nuestra naturaleza
y eso me enseñó la marinera desde muy
chica la bailo desde los 3 años de edad
y con ese amor y con esa entrega que
ella solamente me pudo enseñar porque
porque en la marinera la piel no
interesa el color que sea siempre
acaricia
y vibra
asimismo la marinera me presento a
maravillosas personas con un corazón
inmenso con una sencillez y un humildad
que me la presentó desde que tengo tres
años de edad
también me enseñó lo que significa el
sacrificio los retos las caídas las
frustraciones y todo lo que me enseñó la
marinera en un ensayo donde yo anuncié
sabes que marinera no te va a ir lo más
quiero tirar la toalla y por qué porque
ya la marinera no se baila la marinera
se está vendiendo más de una década la
marinera ya no se baila ya no se cuentan
las historias del día a día se vende y
como se vende cuantos títulos me cuelgan
o que favor político comercial
empresarial o legal doy a cambio de algo
que me hace llamar tocar la gloria en la
marinera y la marinera no es un evento
camarín él es la vida misma que
abrazamos todos nosotros día con día
entonces ya cansada de todo lo que me
había enseñado la marinera de bailarle
al amor y por amor a todos y no servirme
del amor iba muriendo y lleva muriendo
con mí esa idea y va muriendo en vida y
artísticamente ya desahuciada yo sentí
que la marinera que ya no me poseía cosa
no se metía en mi cuerpo para
manifestarse como alma propia esta es
una experiencia que les quiero compartir
y me presento un alumno con una sonrisa
y una calidez que envolvía realmente
todo lo que yo había conocido en el
trayecto de mi carrera y mi vida
artística
y solamente me dijo quiero que tú me
enseñes a bailar marinera y después que
me 6 a bailar marinera que concurse es
conmigo ese alumno yo no sabía si
botarlo o reírme
entonces dominó a esta persona porque no
soy perfecta y si estoy para acá no es
para decir que soy un modelo de vida o
un rol de un rol de vida no tengo mil y
un defectos y se los simplifica de esta
manera ese hombre es mi esposo ahora y
la mariner yo me lo presentó en el
momento más horrible artísticamente
hablando y es tan así que dominó de esta
persona que me hizo sentir viva otro
momento en el cual sentí que la marinera
por alma propia fue cuando tenía 20
semanas de embarazo y me dicen que mi
hija venía con síndrome de down y que no
le encontraban el pie derecho cuando me
dieron esa noticia en el país donde vivo
actualmente también me propusieron
terminar mi embarazo porque en el país
donde vivo terminar un embarazo no
deseado es completamente legal le soy
sincera la idea de
de terminar mi embarazo por mi mente
pero si yo de quitarme la vida
soy muy sincera en desierto es ese
sentimiento de culpa ese sentimiento de
ignorancia completamente lo que es la
marinera perdón lo que es el síndrome de
dow me atacaron durante meses con esa
idea quítate tú la vida cuando pasaban
las crisis y terminaba en el suelo
literalmente que no puedo soportar más
estas preguntas de por qué a mí porque
me sucedió a mí es cuando sucedía esta
magia es cuando la mariana otra vez
salió tomo esa energía que yo le había
dado durante años y me levantaba porque
gritaba y decía no me puedo matar la
desesperación porque ella merece vivir
yo no
a ese punto la marinera vino y dijo no
milagros levántate baila el
misteriosamente bailaba y cuando sonar
la música es cuando sonaba algo mágico a
pesar de que nos habían dicho que mi
hija no se podía mover en el vientre por
su condición por los agujeros que tenía
el corazón y milly un diagnóstico esta
bebé pateaba y se movía fuertísimo y ahí
me conectaba con el movimiento y con un
gran melodía de la marina iglesia ha
tocado la peor mamá impaciente
intolerante perfeccionista y ahora qué
voy a hacer y ahí es cuando la marinera
se materializó y me dijo milagros va a
ir la sigue fuerza ánimo con esta y así
me conecté con ella y la marinera me
salvó la vida y por ende la vida de mi
hijo
y les tengo eternamente agradecido
porque para eso creo que me preparo
actualmente qué es lo que hago qué
belleza descubierto con el baile no esto
no el maquillaje no el pelo del
vestuario la idea que les quiero dejar
ahora es que cuando tú tengas un arte un
talento una habilidad cuando tú lo
respetas lo alimentas lo nutren te
entregas y le das amor ese talento cobra
un alma propia y te va a salvar la vida
y cuando salve tu vida te deja el poder
de salvar otras vidas dice la idea que
les quiero dejar escúchelo no solamente
con los ayudo sino por favor con el
corazón
actualmente la belleza del baile que ha
aprendido a través del movimiento es
entregar mis manos mis brazos mi cuerpo
a muchos niños que no pueden caminar o
que no pueden hablar
pero en el movimiento nos conectamos vas
a bailar en esta vida y vas a bailar con
muchas personas y vas a ser la luz y va
y vas a hacer la alegría de muchas
personas bailen gocen sientan
comuníquense ese elemento de
comunicación no tenemos todos los seres
humanos así el que no pueda hablar así
el que no se pueda parar y esa es la
belleza del baile esa es la belleza que
les he querido compartir y quiero
terminar mi presentación con un
movimiento sin palabras y que lo siento
[Aplausos]